how do you feel about i mean alabama's
having a
a cool wave in music i feel like i feel
good about this [ __ ] for real cause like
we've been waiting for a window for so
many years you feeling like
we had a whole we had a real gap
before we even got an artist you feeling
like for a long at times and like rich
boy you feel me
uh yellow [ __ ] like that it was really
rich boy and yellow wolf and don't be
dope rest in peace for the long
night we just coming back to back you
feeling like
i ain't gonna lie who who are some of
your favorite artists out of the city
man i'm [ __ ] with uh
musket uh honeycomb oh you talking about
my city yeah
just out of the state of alabama
honeycomb
[ __ ] oh
mgm lit right low i'm [ __ ] here but
i'm [ __ ] with you right now it's a
wave man y'all [ __ ] over there
wait is muskie the track star guy yeah i
didn't know he's from there even
yeah no [ __ ] idea that what i'm
saying we come somewhere we're coming
from
yeah ain't going real we got young blue
yo blue's moving oh god what and he's
have you ever met him
yeah he's a a smart kid like i feel like
he's like a got his head on his shoulder
yeah he can either or
like he just don't look at you yeah yeah
he knows something
he knows something for sure yeah when i
was talking i'm like yo you're different
man this guy's got restaurants
yeah real tough young [ __ ] too lives in
biloxi don't gotta pay state tax because
he's in mississippi
he's chilling